from a movie monster to horror icon
Megan could be the Monstrous voice of a
new generation new horror villains drop
all the time and compelling characters
like malignant's Gabriel and the
babadook's titular entity show that
filmmakers have no shortage of
imagination when it comes to creating
visually impressive villains still apart
from the babadook's unlikely stint as a
meme worthy lgbtq plus icon most horror
monsters have a long way to go before
they really reach the status of an icon
Megan on the other hand was a different
beast from the point that the first
trailer dropped when the film itself
turned out to be even more entertaining
than the doll's dance moves and the
promotional material it was clear that
gen Z has received its first horror icon
Megan the killer friend bot is Sassy
smart funny infinitely memeable and
relatable somehow what's more her
potential to become a genre Mainstay is
vast and everyone involved knows it
Universal was already interested in a
Megan sequel before the movie premiered
and after a successful 30 million dollar
debut the age of Megan has officially
Just Begun you should probably run while
murder clowns and ax killers are just as
terrifying to younger Generations as
they are to any other cohort of people
gen Z is notably the first truly digital
generation that has never known a world
without the internet thus your average
genzir is likely far more personally
familiar with advanced technology than
they are with circuses or wood cutting
implements right away that's a point for
Megan whose horror and humor are
Technology based there's also the fact
that the creepy doll's very nature as a
go-getter who values its loved ones and
has an extremely practical though
murderous approach to problem solving is
quite close to gen Z's core values
Roberta cats of Stanford University
describes gen z thoughtfully a typical
gen zir is the self-driver who deeply
cares about others strives for a diverse
Community is highly collaborative and
social values flexibility relevance
authenticity and non-hierarchical
Leadership and while dismayed about
inherited issues like climate change has
a pragmatic attitude about the work that
has to be done to address those issues
of course as variety notes a clever
shrewd marketing strategy that went hard
at Tick Tock and Twitter memeability
played a part in giving Megan its
deserved horror queen crown going viral
has translated into both cultural status
and box office slugs it's almost certain
that a torrent of imitators will attempt
to recreate Megan's success with their
own takes on memeable marketable horror
that guns for viral attention in hopes
of creating horror icons of their own
unfortunately it's also pretty likely
that things won't be that easy a horror
icon like the Megan robot is lightning
in a bottle rare and tough to replicate
even when all the ingredients are
clearly visible besides since Megan will
likely occupy the collective new horror
icon headspace for the immediate future
there's not much room for newcomers as
such it may be more interesting to view
Megan as the spearhead of a general
horror Trend that's been emerging in
recent years and only seems to be
growing stronger horror has always been
at its strongest when it draws from
familiar experience and recent movies
have been heavily inspired by
experiences that are far more inherently
familiar to gen Z than Immortal machete
man stalking summer camps can ever hope
to be from Candyman to get out horror
has always been excellent at tackling
social and cultural Affairs now that
more and more gen Z filmmakers are
hitting their horror stride the focus
has simply shifted to what they know
well shedding the pre-online world of
their predecessors in the process this
will no doubt result in countless
amazing horror films and icons in the
future